the only villains bigger than thanos so
far have to be the costumes marvel
actors are forced to wear they've been
compared to torture check out why these
20 marvel actors hated their costumes
and what five surprisingly loved theirs
so is this how you normally look
more or less
number one the mcu's biggest complainer
tom holland has spoken about how much he
dislikes his spidey suit many times over
the years the poor guy has to time his
bathroom breaks because it takes around
45 minutes to get out of the suit again
i asked for a zip and i didn't get one
part of the struggle taking off the
spidey suit is that the zipper gets
caught sometimes and it's a nightmare
i'll have like half of it off and i'm
like please just get this thing off of
me but there is a fix to this problem
that's why we have
bottles of blue he struggles with the
mask too poor tom has to drink his
frappuccino through a straw that comes
down through the spider suit eye socket
zendaya's wondering what happens if he
pukes in costume this is a genuine
concern yes tom also had to wear a
freaking thong no exceptions and he
can't really see much of anything which
resulted in him getting punched in the
head when he wasn't given a sound cue
and he doesn't find the suit flattering
at all saying it makes you look small in
all the places you don't want to look
small
number two women aren't the only ones
who get objectified in superhero
costumes andrew garfield felt
uncomfortable in the spidey suit because
it was completely skin tight saying i
knew there were paparazzi taking
terrible unflattering shots of my you
know my everything number three toby
mcguire is the only one of the three
whose spidey costume was updated to
accommodate bathroom needs his costume
was remodeled to include a vent so he
could go without having to take the
entire suit off it only makes sense time
is money in hollywood and a long
bathroom break can cost a lot of money
they did it for og spidey in the early
2000s so they can do it for the rest of
the actors now
just saying
number four not everybody in the
spiderverse hated their costume jake
gyllenhaal might be the number one fan
of his costume i didn't know how much i
was gonna love it he pushed to have it
in more scenes gyllenhaal wandered
around in the suit for many of his not
so super moments instead of wearing
street clothing he didn't have to he
wanted to asking can i be in the costume
i really feel the character i get it
number five at least his day ends on a
high note paul bettany's skin was
getting tattered working six days a week
he ends his day sipping on a beer
chilling in a sauna to help loosen the
costume from his body the most
frustrating part of the costume though
is that it makes it hard to hear
number six turns out spandex aren't so
hot scarlett johansson had her
dermatologist on speed dial she was
consistently so hot and sweaty that it
gave her skin conditions and she was
wringing out her socks every day
she also came close to a heat stroke
while recording and the suit got
destroyed so often she was in a new one
every few days it was tolerable at best
on day one but by day three she was
longing for fresh spandex
number seven definitely less than super
that's what elizabeth olsen had to say
about her costume she's the only mcu
hero with visible cleavage which she
finds is kind of limiting during action
sequences
number eight not all superheroes hate
their capes though salma hayek loved her
costume despite fears of claustrophobia
she loved the look so much she cried
when she first saw herself wearing it
number nine a love-hate relationship the
thrill built for simulu with every piece
of his costume he tried on when he got
that third and final piece on it was
just
magic it sent chills up his spine and
and it just all of a sudden got so
emotional unfortunately as much as he
loved it after five days in it the
zippers were incredibly annoying and he
admitted to hating it expectations meet
reality
number 10 sometimes an actor just needs
to breathe like his co-stars sebastian
stan struggled with the heat he feared
falling over or passing out some days he
would rip his mask off his face just to
get a breath of fresh air flexibility
was a major issue so rehearsing out of
costume didn't translate once he got on
set but he's a pro and chose to wear the
least mobile arms because they looked
the coolest i always wanted to make it
tighter
number 11 back in the good old days
costumes were even worse they're much
more comfortable now than they were
before nobody knows how uncomfortable
those costumes are willem dafoe's
costume for no way home is more flexible
and he can do more in it there have been
upgrades on the costume let's say
originally to be fitted for the green
goblin costume it took them eight hours
of sticking pieces to him now he just
gets his body scanned and his job is
done
number 12 less cgi almost always makes a
movie better
jamie foxx is much happier to be his own
skin tone in spider-man no way home and
i didn't have to be blue and things like
that jamie didn't particularly hate
being blue but now he's thrilled to look
more like himself he felt like his old
costume was just trying too hard
number 13 just smile through the pain og
venom actor topher grace's fangs were
bruising his gums
and like many of the other superhero
actors he had no way to use the bathroom
in his costume either
number 14. from puppets to cgi alfred
molina may just be the exception in the
spider-verse he absolutely loved the
upgrades to doc ock being released from
the puppetry allowed him a lot more
freedom with the character and he loved
it like he absolutely loved it number 15
you may take his name but you will never
take his armor falcon and the winter
soldier actor wyatt russell who played
the new cap found his costume was like
the rest of the marvel gangs except tack
on painful the suit was so bad that he
had an old shoulder injury flare up
number 16 what's worse struggling to
breathe or not being able to scratch
that itch chadwick boseman's spandex
were tight and suffocating to get into
restricting his chest he suffered from
anxiety attacks when that happened he
had to get the suit off as quickly as
possible and there was sweat rolling
down his body that made him itchy and he
couldn't scratch
number 17. this reminds us of that old
wives tale about peeing in a public pool
rebecca romain's mystique costume is the
most revealing of all the marvel
characters
she was naked aside from paint and her
prosthetics which made her super
uncomfortable and going to the bathroom
was embarrassing because there was blue
paint on everything everybody knew when
she used the bathroom because the toilet
seat was blue
number 18 why didn't they design
mystique to have a bodysuit from the
beginning while romaine's eight hour
makeup process was streamlined for
jennifer lawrence down to around three
it still wasn't a fun process
and going to the bathroom was super
awkward for her too she revealed she
would have to pee out of a funnel
standing up
she joked that the designers thought she
doesn't go to the bathroom she's a girl
and jayla had such a negative reaction
to the blue paint that they had to call
a doctor to set
after that they gave her a bodysuit
instead
number 19. the suit broke the poor man
in the first iron man movie robert
downey jr wore a full metal suit that
weighed a hundred pounds rdj struggled
with breathing in the mask was blinded
by its led lights and the suit was
pinchy downey admitted i'm not
claustrophobic but after moving around
in it for a couple hours your spirit is
kind of broken and you're like okay time
to bring in the sun team number 20. this
actress liked her suit more than her
wellness eggs while rdj was struggling
with his metal suit gwyneth paltrow
loved every minute in hers
well she only spent a couple days in it
she would have gladly put the armor back
on yeah i was like don't we need another
scene or pepper's flying around
number 21 he got off lucky for a solid
second captain america's helmet gave
chris evans a headache it was tight
sweaty uncomfortable and made it hard to
hear while he didn't like his usual
costume he did really love his stealth
suit from the winter soldier he liked
that suit so much he kept pushing for
them to bring it back but the classic
red won out
number 22 he did not get off lucky at
all chris hemsworth has had a few not so
great experiences with costumes the
first is with the regular thor costume
by month 3 in the suit it gets hard to
wake up and put the thing on every
morning the fat suit was also terrible
the thing weighed about 60 to 70 pounds
before adding armor
and like every other suit it was
restrictive uncomfortable and super hot
number 23 you can't sit with us if you
don't have a cool suit
mark ruffalo just felt plain embarrassed
while all his other actor friends got to
wear cool looking suits all the time he
was just done up in a mocap suit he
never felt as cool or as intimidating as
the others
number 24 i'm melting i'm melting
dave bautista spent five hours in the
makeup chair he had to stand for most of
it with his arms sticking out and
rubbing the makeup off at the end of the
day was so tough on his body his skin
looked like hamburger meat he spent time
in the sauna to melt off the prosthetics
he and paul bettany aren't the only ones
to do so michael b jordan went through a
similar process to remove all those scar
marks
number 25 she's calling it like she sees
it
evangeline lily absolutely adores her
costume it makes her feel sexy
she thinks it's cool killer powerful
modern strong and it made me feel like a
superhero she also called out all the
men for complaining about their suits
she was surprised it wasn't so bad which
led her to question if men are just used
to feeling more comfortable in their
clothing while she wears heels to work
all day you get used to it you tune it
out that's 25 actors who had a lot of
feelings about their costumes
just let the actors complain okay every
time they walk into one of those
interview rooms it's the equivalent of
being asked hi honey how was your day
whose complaints surprised you the most
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching